the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video well my
friends we have finally heard something
from the elusive d.b weiss former
showrunner and co-creator of game of
thrones as you all know db weiss as well
as david benioff wore the game of
thrones writers for the 8 season run of
the show now unless you have been living
under a rock you know that game of
thrones is still considered as one of
the greatest shows ever made as well as
one of the most financially successful
shows in history even now nearly three
years after its finale aired on hbo game
of thrones is still one of the most
talked about shows on social media just
about everyone including millions of
fans and celebrities have had something
to say about game of thrones since its
divisive ending
well everyone except for the men who
wrote the show
that's right after game of thrones ended
and broke the internet its writers david
and dan essentially vanished for a
number of years not only have they
stayed silent about the show's ending
but they have even avoided showing up at
different speaking engagements regarding
hbo's massively successful show i think
we can all assume they did not want to
face the enormous amount of backlash
that was sure to be thrown their way as
you all know there are millions of fans
who are still upset with david and dan
because of how they ended game of
thrones many fans believe they ruined a
show that was once destined to be
regarded as the greatest show ever made
now since the ending of game of thrones
the fans have been dying to hear from
the original show's creators i for one
would certainly love to ask them some
things about the final season
unfortunately we may never get all the
answers we want but db weiss did finally
sit down for an interview with
entertainment weekly when he discussed
his upcoming feature film that will be
released on netflix now during the
interview he did answer some questions
about game of thrones as well as hbo's
upcoming game of thrones successor shows
let me show you what the article says
it says hbo is going all in on the game
of thrones universe with the upcoming
release of house of the dragon later
this year as well as multiple spin-offs
that are still in the early stages of
development but with all the throne's
goodness coming our way d.b weiss who
co-created the original show with david
benioff reaffirms their commitment to
moving away from the franchise dby said
all in we were 11 years making that show
when i say 11 years it was full on all
in all day every day for 11 years it was
the best decade of our lives it still
kind of feels like a dream but we got to
a place where it was clear to us that we
had reached the end of what made sense
for us to be involved within that world
that we lived in
it still kind of feels like a dream but
we got to a place where it was clear to
us that we had reached the end of what
made sense for us to be involved within
that world that we lived in it just felt
like for us it was time to move on and
get excited and terrified about building
something else
building lots of something else's we
never saw more game of thrones shows as
something that made sense for us to be
involved with
what you just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things i have ever heard
at no point
in your rambling incoherent response
were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought
everyone in this room is now dumber for
having listened to it
i award you no points
and may god have mercy on your soul
he doesn't say much about the show in
fact what he said really doesn't make a
whole lot of sense
it's almost as if they want to avoid
discussing the one thing that made them
rich and famous
now for those of you who have been
worried that david and dan will be
working on house of the dragon or any of
the other game of thrones shows should
now see that they will not be involved
whatsoever in fact david and dan no
longer work for hbo they now have a new
deal on netflix which i think is a good
thing i know i'm not the only one who's
happy they will not be working on house
of the dragon
as you can see they obviously want
nothing else to do with george rr
martin's a song of ice and fire universe
i think they made that abundantly clear
with how fast they wanted to end game of
thrones knowing damn well that show
needed far more seasons than they gave
it to properly tell that story now i've
said this once but i will say it again i
will never understand why they didn't
bring in more writers to help them with
game of thrones they have admitted in
more than one interview that they were
basically getting exhausted working on
that show which is understandable
however if that's the case why not bring
in more writers to help you carry that
heavy load we all know hbo offered them
more money and more seasons but for some
reason they did not want to spend any of
that money where they needed it the most
that is one thing that will never make
sense to me
it actually hurts to think about how
great game of thrones could have been
whenever i think about how amazing those
first four seasons are at the end of the
day i guess it really doesn't matter
what they say
nothing will ever go back and fix the
mistakes that were made although i would
still like to know exactly what was
happening behind the scenes
one day i hope someone does release a
novel revealing everything that happened
during the making of what could have
been the greatest show ever made
[Music]
are you all happy with the way your
things end with the outcome of the show
now personally
the fray it's a little bit avengers
assemble and it's a little bit kind of
like well that was totally what season
seven was all about wasn't it
exactly character development
i love it all right
but
i really need to shut up you're brave
[Laughter]
oh my god
um
kit
was really fine with it i was pissed
i was pissed that it wasn't me killing
the night king i could have i would have
i would have given you like i'd bet you
thousands
before we read the finals i was like
yeah it's definitely me
jon snow has always been the hero the
one who's been the savior but
it
just didn't seem right to us for this
moment
if you could describe the season finale
of game of thrones in one word
how would you describe it
disappointing
have you shot your final scenes yet and
are you
happy with how things ended
yeah
she didn't say yes you didn't say yes
best season ever
[Music]
[Music]
you